thank you
finally back on UK soil and this says it
all
so I'm safe I'm so glad they're home
Yasmine is reunited with her mother and
grandmother after no news for days
Sharma and her mother have been awake
for 24 hours they left Sudan in the
middle of the night for Cyprus and now
they're home into the arms of loved ones
it was very bad feeling because any
minute I feel as if I will die well it
was very I
it was very very very difficult
Marta Sim is waiting for his sister who
went as a holiday maker but is now
returning as an evacuee has she gone for
holiday and she's stuck there because
the words are there
and
just how hard they bring her safe today
I'm happy for that very happy they are
the first British Nationals to be flown
out of Sudan by the UK government they
stepped off this chartered aircraft one
of at least four being laid on after
criticism the government has been too
slow to act but evacuating 4 000 UK
Nationals isn't simple
these families behind me are just some
of the over 100 people that were on that
first flight that landed here at
Stansted Airport speaking to them many
of them are in Shock they are dealing
with a lot of grief and whilst many of
them say they're happy to be here
they're heartbroken for the people
they've left behind
her Fizz hasn't slept in three days he's
thinking of his wife and four children
currently Bound for Cyprus this is his
nine-year-old on the RAF aircraft he
says he had to fight with the foreign
office to get them on it
Communications are very bad
we don't know where to go
who to talk to a war is going on people
are getting killed
and you are listening
to people who are not giving you any
kind of hope
shutting you down telling you
you might not get through
when you're looking for hope
they tell you you might not make it
her Fizz is hanging on to hope
a temporary and short ceasefire has
provided this window of opportunity
time and patience for Britain's stuck in
Sudan is running out and there are still
so many who don't know when they'll be
home ashnaharana Sky News at Stansted
Airport